- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Kay] So I would like to start with
acknowledgments. So the work I'm going to
present is actually the work of many, many
people who are involved in sequencing
these two genomes I'm going to talk about
and helped analyzing them. I will give
some more credit during the talk. So let
me start by just introducing the samples
that were used to generate these
sequences. So, both of these samples were
found in the Denisova Cave in the Altai
Mountains in Russia. And one was actually
a small finger bone that you see here on
top, yeah. And another one was a small toe
bone that you see on the bottom. And the
reason that we are actually having two
genomes from the same place has to do with
the fact that the Denisova Cave actually
preserves the DNA in these bones
particularly well. It's one of those
exceptional place where most of the DNA
that we get out of these very old bones
really comes from the individual that died
and are not from bacterial or microbial
contamination. So what this allows us also
to do is to not just sequence these
genomes to a low coverage, meaning just a
couple of sequences from the nuclear
genome, but we can actually sequence them
many times over. And how this looks like,
then, is that you have small sequences
stacking up like this that are distributed
randomly over the entire genome, and you
always have several of those for each
position. And so taken together, you have
34 coverage meaning on an average position
in a genome, you will have 30 different
fragments for the finger bone, and for the
toe bone you have 50 fragments. So using
these genomes, then, to actually
understand how they're related, you see
that one of those two genomes that we
produced from this cave falls together
with other Neandertals that we have
sequenced before to lower coverage. And we
call this the Altai Neandertal. And the
second individual, the nuclear genome is
from a sister group of Neandertals that we
call the Denisovan because they fall
outside of the variation that we observe
of Neandertals. So they are more closely
related to Neandertals but they are not
looking close enough related to deserve to
be just called a Neandertal and we rather
call them Denisovan. So one of the
questions that you might ask yourself is,
"Why are we actually bothering with
sequencing these genome so deeply? Why do
we sequence them 30 or even 50 times
over?" And the reason for this is the fact
that we are diploid organism. So we are
actually having each chromosome twice. One
complete set is inherited from the mother,
and another complete set of chromosomes is
inherited from the father. And so, one of
the things that you can do when you have
so many fragments and so many sequences is
you can call confidently the differences
between these two copies that you have
from the mother and the father. And this
is really the reason why we are sequencing
it so deeply so that we can call the
differences between these chromosomes. And
one of the most easy analysis that you can
actually do once we have sequenced so
deeply and called these differences
between the chromosomes is to just asks
how different are they on average. So this
is called heterozygosity. And you can
actually put this into perspective by also
showing, as in this plot, the level of
heterozygosity, so the level of
differences between the chromosomes in
modern humans, in present-day modern
humans. And we have some individuals from
Africa here and some individuals from
outside of Africa and what you can see is
that Africans have about 1 in 1,000
differences between the chromosomes that
they inherited from the mother and the
father, while non-Africans have between
the 6 and 8 in 10,000. And the archaics
are much reduced compared to both of these
present-day human populations, or
present-day human regions. And they are at
a level of 2 to 3 in 10,000. And there's
even a quite significant difference
between the two archaics and that the
Denisovan is higher than the Neandertals.
So the Neandertal is further reduced. So
one can actually look into this in more
detail by looking over the chromosomes. So
just going in a small window over the
chromosomes and just counting the
differences that you observed. And we have
done this here for a French individual,
the Denisovan and the Altai Neandertal.
And what you can see is that the level of
heterozygosity, so the differences between
the chromosomes, varies over the genome.
But there's one thing that is very special
and that is that the Altai Neandertal has
this very long stretch, here for instance
on chromosome 21, there are other
stretches like this on the other
chromosomes, where there is hardly any
difference between the two parental
copies. And so now, what one can do is one
can actually take the size of these
stretches and how much of the genome is
actually residing in those stretches to
calculate back how closely related the
parents would have to be to generate
stretches like this. And this is an
analysis that Flora Fief [SP] in Monty
Slatkin's lab in Berkeley was carrying out
for the analysis of the Altai Neandertal
genome. And what she found is that there
are several different relationships
between the parents possible that would
actually generate exactly the patterns
that we see. And so I guess one easy way
to say this is that the parents of this
individual would have to be at least
related on the level of whole siblings to
generate these patterns. So they were
closely related. And then you can take a
step further and you just take your
prediction of how much you would actually
expect in terms of long stretches that are
looking like this, almost identical, and
you just ask if I would subtract now,
based on what I understood the family
relationship of the parents would be, if I
subtract this away, is there actually
anything left? And this is in fact the
case, so for the Altai Neandertal you
still see an excess over the stretches
that you see in the Denisovan and in
modern humans. And this actually means
that this is not just a singular event
that just once happened, that just by
chance the parents were closely related,
but also further back in the past there
were probably closely related ancestors.
So another topic that I would like to talk
about is Archaic Admixture. And so we
already heard about archaic admixture from
Neandertals and Denisovans into modern
humans. What I would like to talk about is
really archaic admixture between both
archaics. But before I get to this, I
would actually like to go a little bit
deeper into how we actually know what
signal we have to look for to understand
that there's really admixture. And so, as
a very simple way of depicting this, just
imagine that you have a certain individual
and of course, as I already explained,
every chromosome has two copies so this
individual has these two copies of a
certain chromosome, an arbitrary one. Of
course, you can go back to its parents and
one of those copies will come from the
father and the other one will come from
the mother. So I can paint them now blue
and red. But I can also go a step further
and actually paint them according to
whether they come from the grandparents or
from which grandparent they come. And what
you see in this picture now is that there
is actually a process called recombination
that is actually mixing up these different
chromosomes in the parents of the
individual. So now you have kind of these
random stretches from all the grandparents
that are painting these chromosomes. And
of course, you can take another step,
another step, another step. And so
essentially what this means is that you're
breaking up the ancestry...when you go
through the ancestors, you kind of jump
between different ancestries when you go
over the chromosome. So you change which
ancestors' genome you look at. And so when
you repeat this process for a very long
time and let's say you have ancestry from
one population for most of the genome, but
you have a couple of ancestors from a
different human group hiding among your
ancestors, then what's the most common
outcome will be is that you will have
these short stretches where one of the
chromosomes actually shows this ancestry
of this other human group while the other
chromosome is actually looking like the
chromosome of the majority of the groups,
because these stretches will be randomly
replaced on your two chromosomes. And now
we can actually use the Altai Neandertal
and the Denisovan to find out whether
there is any Neandertal ancestry in the
Denisovan, or whether there is any
Denisovan ancestry in the Neandertal
individual that we sequenced. And so in
one direction, just showing so if
Neandertals would contribute to the
Denisovan what we would expect is that
there are some stretches where the
Denisovan looks very much like a
Neandertal but on the other chromosome, we
would expect that it actually looks like a
normal Denisovan. That means that the two
chromosomes are actually very different.
And so the prediction that this makes is
that if you go to regions where, that's
shown here on the left-hand side, so the
X-scale is giving you how closely related
you can make any particular window that
you look through, how closely related you
can actually make that to the other
archaic. So when you have windows where
the Altai Neandertal is very closely
related to the Denisovan, shown here in
blue, you actually see no effect but if
you look in the same for the Denisovans
when the Denisovan can be made very
closely related, or it looks actually very
closely related to the Altai Neandertal,
you see that the two chromosomes are very
different, and this is shown here in red
at this position. So this is a hallmarks
sign that there is actually among the
ancestors of the Denisovan some Neandertal
ancestry. The last signal I want to talk
about is actually the one of unknown
archaic material that we found in the
Denisovan. And so the first signal that we
saw for that is really just when you look
for divergence to Africa, so that's
nothing else than just looking for how
many differences we observe. We actually
see when we take larger windows and we
just compare to an African that the
Denisovan is always a little bit more
different than the Altai Neandertal. So
these two distributions that you see here,
the one of the Denisovan in blue is
slightly shifted to the right. And you can
look even deeper into this by actually
looking at different allele frequencies
and divide up your comparison by how many
Africans actually carry a certain derived
variant, meaning a new variant that
occurred sometime after the split from
chimpanzee. And when all Africans are the
same, you actually see that the signal is
the strongest. So you see the most
differences. And in an analysis that also
Monty Slatkin's lab carried out in
Berkeley with Fernando Racimo, what they
did was essentially taking the signals
that I just described and they tried three
different models to actually compare how
this could come about. And so the first
model assumes that there was gene flow
from Neandertals into the common ancestor
of all modern humans. The second model is
assuming that all modern humans actually
gave some material to the Neandertals. And
so these first two models are essentially
trying to explain how you could make the
Neandertals and the modern humans more
closely related. And the last model is one
where you have some lineage that we
haven't observed, so we don't know what it
is, that contributed to the Denisovans and
that would make the Denisovan more
distantly related to modern humans. And so
in most...comparison model three was
actually the best explanation that we
could find for the data. And so we believe
that there is this super archaic admixture
of some very deeply divergent lineage into
the Denisovan. So, what I would like to
say in the end is...or what I would like
to show in the end is really just a
general overview of the different gene
flows that we have now observed. And this
picture is not quite complete yet. So what
you can see is that we have the ancestry,
this deeply divergent ancestor that
contributed to Denisovans. We have the
Neandertal admixture into the modern
humans. We have contributions from
Denisovan to modern humans. And the
Neandertal admixture into the Denisovans
that I just talked about. And it seems
that there is, by now, there are also
other publications that say that there are
contributions to Africans and so on and so
on. And so, I think what this all means
when you sum it up is that these different
types of admixtures are actually something
that is quite common. So it actually
happens quite a lot in the past and it is
something that is really a transition in
our thinking because originally, I think
we were all very skeptical that there was
actually any admixture between these
archaic groups. And with this I would like
to end and say thank you for your
attention.
♪ [music] ♪